Hey guys, what's up? It's Kim. Welcome back to Psych2Go.
Today's video is going to get super, super crazy.
So, let's just go right on into it.
Also, sidenote, I've gotten so many comments about people being so annoyed that I don't make my bed.
So, as a Christmas present to all of you I made my bed today.
So, today's video, I'm going to be telling you all about five super crazy, super insane, not very common mental disorders.
That most of you probably have never even heard about before.
Starting at number one we have Cotard syndrome.
Now, have you ever imagined what it would be like to just wake up dead?
but like, still be able to experience everything around you.
Basically, that's exactly what people with this disorder go through every single day of their life.
And although it's not technically classified in the DSM
it is still a mental disorder where the sufferers truly, completely believe that they are dead
or decomposing.
They're going through their complete daily lives as they would normally but they think
that they are dead.
And the possible causes for this vary from a simple to adverse drug reaction
to actual misfirings in the brain.
Now, moving on to number two we have Capgras syndrome
This one is also known as impostor syndrome.
This is the belief that a familiar person or place has been replaced with an impostor.
An exact duplicate of this person or place.
And even though it is usually, typically, seen with dementia
it can also come with schizophrenia, bipolar disorder, or in people with an injury or brain disease.
Number three is body integrity disorder.
Now, this disorder is the belief that one is disabled.
Even though they are completely fine.
Many of these people believe they're arms, legs or toes are foreign objects.
And that they shouldn't be able to used them, and that they should not be on their body.
Because they feel like they are not able to use them, they go to great lengths to actually amputate these limbs
that they believe are disabled.
There are a number of different theories as to what causes this
but there are no actual supported proven facts as to why people experience this disorder.
And, next, number four is called fugue state.
This one is kind of more just a symptom rather than an actual whole disorder.
It can appear in multiple different disorders
as a symptom.
Basically what happens is this person completely blanks and forgets who they are.
And becomes a completely, entirely different person.
And, last but not least, number five is called Genital Retraction Syndrome.
Now, this one is where a person holds the completely wrong belief that their genitals
will suddenly just retract into their body.
This is a debilitating fear for those who suffer from it and interferes with their every day life.
This belief also comes with the fear that they will die upon retraction of their genitals.
There you guys go, those are the five craziest diseases that are really not that common
and most people don't know about.
So, I hope you guys enjoyed it, make sure to go on over click that big red subscribe button
Subscribe to Psy2Go for so many more interesting videos
all about psychology and if you want you can also go ahead to my channel the link will be
in the description box below to check out my videos as well.
Thanks so much for watching guys, see you next time. Bye.